yeah hello everyone and thank you so
much uh aria
and uh uh dr professor sona
and snarlika to help and all the
bioclues members
to help us uh guide through the entire
program and how it will be what are the
benefits what are the applications
whom this is for so uh genomics in the
virtual lab
and this is the second version of it so
we did genomics in the virtual lab
in 2020 and we have had like really
amazing results
working with um many high school
students and also
undergraduate and postgraduate students
from india joined
and many other places who would want to
get
uh understanding of how genomics is
applied
in different areas of bioinformatics
and different areas of life science and
biological research
so uh one thing that i think
we have discussed quite a bit is the
application
of genomic research in um
in biomedical research in translational
biomedical research
but with our collaborators and the
phases of this program which i'll be
going through right now with you all of
you
uh we will learn that uh that you will
learn that that genomics can be applied
to a various
uh different areas like agriculture and
many of you might have
uh have an uh bend towards working on
something like
that so we will be able to help you that
during the project phase as well
so now talking about the program so it
has
the the entire program is divided into
uh thinking of a concept of how genomics
can be
applied in basic research and as well as
how genomics can be applied to
understand
healthcare research and healthcare
system and improve the healthcare system
so that from developing a hypothesis to
be able to work on translational
research
so those are some of the objectives of
this program
so introducing uh the uh program from
the for the
from the first week we will have the
introduction to bioinformatics session
so that will be the
first session and as if you already have
said that this session will be
freely available to uh those who are
interested
in joining the entire program so in this
session
we will start with uh the basic of
bioinformatics
understand how bioinformatics started
understands its application and will go
through
a course work of introduction to
bioinformatics which is available
on the platform that you will have
access to
so uh followed by that the second day we
will be learning about protein structure
and function this will be
again uh with the help of uh dr sona
here
uh professor sona here she will be uh
she'll be leading this session and
letting us learn about how protein
structure and functions
are related and then we will learn about
sequence analysis and sequence alignment
and phylogenetic analysis
and how these evolutionary and analysis
helps in evolutionary and
understanding of evolutionary distances
and then
the research that enables us to learn
about the origin
and understand all those questions that
are relevant to
today's biomedical problems so next
session we will have we will have about
mutations and 3d structures and by this
time we will learn about how we can
apply some of these techniques on
different data sets so we
we started to work on data sets and then
we have a review and activity session
and this will be a guest session we will
have games and
we will have different kind of
activities that will be associated with
the
you know with aspects of genomics and
the guest lecture will involve
someone which is again a surprise and
which will
be uh which we will be announcing very
soon
uh will give you an insight of how
genomics can apply
can up is being applied and is helping a
lot of people
uh with many disabilities and problems
so after the completion of the first
week and
uh that will be uh by 25th uh
25th june we will be finishing the last
session and during the weekend
we'll have weekend activities and during
this time
before the end of the week we will be
providing you with the details of
the assignments and how you can
complete the assignment and what all
other elements are there
that you need to complete and we will be
sharing those details with you the data
sets
and then we will have a review session
starting next week where we will be
reviewing the video presentations
and we already have a lot of examples uh
of people completing these
weekend activities and i would request
sunalika if you can paste some of the
links
of the participants who completed
the program last time and completed the
weekend activity video
videos so that uh so the students here
can understand that how it could be
so the second week is uh going to be
more about research so you understand
about the structure and function
how genomics is supplied and with the
help of professor sona
we will have such a amazing interactive
sessions that
i can assure and guarantee you that that
because
last time it we have had an amazing
experience going through this entire
journey
learning from her learning from
different tools that she's been part of
while developing so after that we will
be transitioning into the second week
where we will learn about the
application of genomics
in virology and also we will understand
from many case studies
and how you can apply this uh
understanding of genomics
by first doing literature review so we
will start from the
basic of research and we have a very
structured programs
that are leading to uh high value
research
so we have several examples of those and
many of our
interns who have joined are working on
research projects using the same process
so we start from literature review we
will go through different repositories
that you will learn that
learn and you will find interesting
articles and that would be really
an amazing experience for those who are
interested in doing something new
a new research so finding out what has
been done
and how people have achieved those will
be some of the objectives of this
session
and how you can design a process and
design a project
using that information uh with the help
of experts so
this will be the first session after the
review
of the first week's activity so review
process and feedback process
is a very important and a very important
pillar in this
uh bioinformatics research trainings and
especially genomics in the lab
we have sessions or very intensive
sessions like because we have
sessions every day so we'll be expecting
you to be
endorsed with all the experts and make
the most of this opportunity
so next session after learning about and
identifying
the research question we will be
learning about
how you can you know identify viral
species
and strains and do comparative analysis
of violent genomes
understand the viral diversity and then
understand
how this is related how the mutations
are related to the
disease how it is related to the disease
pathology what are the phenotypic to
genotypic changes so how machine
learning and how sorry how
next generation sequencing is playing a
key role
in genomics for biology so that would be
uh the second session of the second week
after that we will learn about more
about the diversity of microbial
communities
so here we will learn about bacterial
genomes and then
we will learn about 16s rnas and we will
learn about
uh how metagenomics can can be applied
to study directly samples that you can
culture
in the lab so that is such a big
advantage that we have with
with the metagenomics technology and you
will be learning about how metagenomics
technology can be applied
to answer many of those important
questions in this
difficult pandemic time where there is
so much of
data is being generated related to kobe
19.
so after that i mean once you have
applied
and learned about how genomics
metagenomics
plays a role in identifying
understanding
in the respect of uh in the respect of
finding these problems that you're
working on
on the aspect of project project and all
so in this session we will learn about
the basic principles between
behind antiviral and active
antibacterial drug
and the approaches for vaccine design so
it's a very important topic
and this can be done like once you have
the holistic understanding and overview
of
all of the topics that we covered we
come to this stage
uh where we are talking about antibodies
and antiviral drugs
so the earlier understanding is equally
important for you to come to this stage
and to make the most and understand the
translational value
of genomics
so the next session after that on
second july will be about hands-on
session
uh analysis of genomics from ncbi virus
so we will be going to ncvi virus
we will be downloading the genomes and
we'll be using the t bind for server
to analyze those genomes so we also have
some of the
project examples that we have already
prepared for you for this program
that you will be utilizing and learning
from so those examples will also be
available
on the learn or mix logic platform that
you have that you will have access
to and subscription to you throughout
this program
so after the completion of second week
we will be working on the weekend
to develop these projects ideas
into presentations so this is a first
step to work towards a
program so one of the practical outcome
of outcomes of this program
is that you get a feedback
from a renowned expert in the field of
genomics in the field of disease
research in the field of
all the other genomic application so we
here we have
uh renowned scientists from all around
india
all around from many renowned
universities in the us
so you will have an expert panel to
discuss
about those project feed project
proposals that you will come up with
so one of the objectives as i was
telling you is to develop an independent
research project that could be reviewed
in this entire process
so after the completion of this two
scheduled uh
you know weeks so the first phase is the
first
week by dr sona the second phase
by omixlogic team on all of this that
you have seen
and the fourth and third and the fourth
week will be
more about research project
so we will be working with experts and
we will have
group sessions and one-on-one sessions
to develop a research project
and that requires a few steps so i'll
just quickly describe you those steps
so the first step to a research project
is to find a problem right
first you have to find a problem uh and
then uh you have to find very
then you have to be very specific and be
focused
that that the problem that you're
interested in
so that uh that would be from you
you will be have you will have that
opportunity to come up with your own
research project
and also will have opportunity to work
on already prepared projects that are
available
so after doing that we will be doing the
literature review as i've already
told you and then we will do exploratory
analysis
where we will look into different data
sets and find those insights from that
data set
so entire process of uh of
uh working from uh week to week
will uh help us develop some of those
research projects and i think uh
i'll also request alika to maybe share
some of those completed research
projects with you here as well
so this is about the program and how we
are going to uh
going to go through this journey one
month journey research journey
and now uh i would like to maybe take
you to the registration process
and show you how you can register for
the program
so maybe i'll find the link in the chat
so sonalika if you can paste the
registration okay it's here
that's the blog post
so once you have a login you will find
yourself
like this like a name and then
in this you'll have a profile so once
you log in you'll see like this
but if you have not login then
then i recommend you to create a free
login on the learn platform
on omixlogic and start exploring
many of the opportunities that we bring
you here
so genomics in the virtual lab you can
find it here
and then
then you go in and then you start your
application so this is a free workshop
and
if you want us to if you want us to send
you
more emails and details about the
program then you can request for more
information and submit your details
uh and as you have joined this program i
believe many of you have already
registered
so you have done your registration part
but now you have to finish your
registration by completing
submitting the registration fees
so i'll go to the registration fees and
i'll describe you different levels of
uh levels that we have
for you to join and explore so beginners
level as i
showed you all of those uh things that
we will do has
all the features uh to complete this
course and get a certificate and then we
have the intermediate level
if you think that you need additional
sessions with one of us
one of the mentors then you can opt for
the intermediate level
so that will give you an option to have
a couple of sessions
with the mentor to guide you and give
you an hands-on
experience by doing screen sharing and
helping you through go through the
resources
and all of that and the tutorials so if
you require that level of
uh that level of support you can opt for
intermediate
and the third option is advance advances
for an
additional work to work additionally on
your project so if you are working on a
project
and if you already have a proposal ready
and you're working maybe with a lab
or you're working with some university
so you can opt for an advanced license
as well so once you select a license and
go here
then you have an option where you can
fill up about the details uh your
card details and how you are going to
submit the fee and at the same time you
can also add promotional codes
so these promotional codes are given up
as scholarships so we have given
a lot of scholarships to our previous
participants before
who would want to join this program and
could not afford the full
price of this uh this homologic program
so you can apply for scholarship and
i'll request an alike
and i'm so sorry that i'll i have to
request you again and again but
uh please if you can share the
scholarship form as well
that would be great so uh yeah as i was
telling you that
with scholarships you can again do this
and if you are a bio clues
member then please reach out to bioclues
uh
bioclues members who are
available here and maybe any any of you
can share the email address to reach out
to and then
you will get a promotional quote from
bioclues and then you can apply that
bioqueues promotion code and get
get scholarship from bioclues as well so
i welcome you all to complete this
and join us for this one month hands-on
mentor guided
research training program and if you
have any
questions and any issues feel free to
reach out to us
and we'll be happy to help you out with
this so my email address is
movie.greatbind.bio
and i i think we'll share other email
addresses as well